isabelle says she became her true self
at 43
a moment of freedom
gender identity clinics mean that
hundreds no longer have to wait decades
now england's only dedicated gender
identity clinic for children and young
people is about to close when i was a a
child
the world told me that is it you're a
boy you can't be anything else so i'm i
made the best of that if i'd have had
the slightest [ __ ] of
light at the end of the tunnel
i would have invested in that
so hard
and then to have it taken away from you
i really feel for
the for those kids who are going through
that at the moment
there is some nervousness as the nhs
looks to open eight new regional clinics
the london-based service will be led by
great ormond street hospital with a
greater focus on other medical needs
during the process
a decade ago the tavis doc clinic was
helping 250 children but the past year
saw 5 000 referrals the standard of care
hasn't matched them the health watchdog
rated this center inadequate earlier
this year after they found that some
children were waiting up to two years
for an appointment what this expansion
shows is that demand is growing
exponentially and the nhs has been
forced to keep up
but former equalities minister kemi
badanok has focused on other issues
blighting the tavistock clinic such as
personal testimonies have destroyed
childhoods and protecting whistleblowing
clinicians from endless harassment
the site was further thrust in the
spotlight by kira bell who bought a high
court case against tavistock challenging
its use of puberty blockers
but this fresh start hasn't been met
with overwhelming relief
there's obviously a load of recruitment
that needs to happen and upskilling on
those staff who've never dealt with
trans young people before
a task that will need to be done quickly
as the first two clinics are due to open
early next year an investment for the
nhs that proves its commitment to
supporting those questioning their
gender identity
ash naharing sky news in north london